à concilier les citoyens avec les hommes
politiques c'est le but du député modem
des pyrénées-atlantiques jean lassalle
il a rencontré hier des habitants de
cagnes-sur-mer qu lens et nice
après ça marche de neuf mois aux quatre
coins de la france il continue donc
d'essayer de rapprocher les français de
leur politique est le passage en force
cette semaine à l'assemblée de la loi
macron ne lui facilite pas la tâche
sur cette affaire puis nous avons le
condensé du malaise actuel de notre pays
les français ont peur et n'ont pas
confiance mais les politiques nous ne
savons plus nous allons et je crois que
ça c'est bien
tradi puisque c'est le gouvernement qui
était mis en minorité par sa propre
majorité
le vote n'a pas eu lieu mais c'est rien
cela qu'il a dégainé le 49 fois que
d'autres gouvernements vont dégainer
mais en ce moment précis
et de relever un écho beaucoup plus
important aux yeux et à la fête des
français parce qu'ils on se sentira que
nous mêmes nous ne savons pas et que sur
une loi sur la caméra passé trois
semaines les nuits entières au dernier
moment on deiana le 49-3 qui est
l'archipel à vème république pour le
faire passer ja je crois que ça
contribue du contest et moi mon
sentiment est que nous devrions nous
politique rappelle d'un maillage
beaucoup plus complet beaucoup plus fort
et jean lassalle au micro à france
blessure de jean baptiste marie